[موسيقى]
المنتخب القطري المستضيف يريد استكمال
مسيرته الناجحه في كاس اسيا والتنافس على
بطاقه النهائي للمره الثانيه تواليا وتخطى
منتخب قطر عقبه اوزباكستان في الدوري ربع
النهائي ندخل المباراه بحافز كبير وهو
اننا على بعد خطوه واحده النهائي انه امر
عظيم لكننا ندرك صعوبه المهمه يتوجب علينا
خوض مباراه في غايه الصعوبه امام ايران
التي لم تحقق اللقب منذ زمن
طويل اما منتخب ايران فتاه لنصف النهائي
بعد الانتصار على اليابان احد المرشحين
للفوز باللقب ويؤكد سعيد عزه الله لاعب
منتخب ايران صعوبه المباراه امام العنابي
الذي سيحظى بدعم جماهيري هائل
همون طور
آقا اكد لنا المدرب اهميه المباراه امام
قطر نحن ايض لاعبون ذو خبره ونعلم انه اذا
وصلنا التفكير في مباراه اليابان فسوف
تكون لدينا مشكله في مباراه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الاربعاء